[موسيقى]
تحقيق السيطره الميدانيه على الارض هي
واحده من اهم المهمات التي يحرص عليها
القاده دائما في المعارك وبالتالي تاتي
اهميه سلاح المدرعات ذلك تاتي اهميه
العربات المصفحه وكذلك ناقلات
الفرنسيه هي واحده من اقدم الشركات
الاوروبيه العامله في هذا المجال على مدى
سنوات ولديها الكثير من المنتجات التي
تخدم بالفعل سلاح المدرعات داخل عدد من
الجيوش حول العالم للحديث اكثر عن احدث
منتجاتها هذه الشركه وكذلك مشاركتها في
معرض ايدكس 2023 هنا في العاصمه
الاماراتيه ابوظبي معنا السيد ايمنويل
رئيس شركه اكوس الفرنسيه اولا مصر اهلا بك
معنا في عسكريتانيا يعني بدايه ما هي ابرز
المنتجات التي تقدمها شركه اركوس الفرنسيه
هنا في ابوظبي في
اشكرك لدعوتي وانا سعيد جدا لوجود هنا
معكم نعم معرض ايدكس مهم جدا بالنسبه لنا
ونعرض فيه احدث منتجاتنا والخدمات التي
توفرها
وكما ترى من خلفي فنحن نعرض اليوم
وهي مركبه ذات درجه عاليه من الحمايه لنقل
الجنود وهي مجهزه باحدث محطات الاسلحه
عاليه التكنولوجيا التي يمكن التحكم فيها
عن بعد وهي معده ايضا بصواريخ مضاده
للدبابات مزوده من قبل شركه فرنسيه اخرى
هي ام بي دي اي كما نحاول في هذا المعرض
استعراض تشكيله متنوعه من منتجاتنا التي
يمكن ان نوفرها لعملائنا في المنطقه
والعالم
مصر الجيش الفرنسي كان بالفعل قام بارسال
عدد من منتجات اركوس الى الاوكرانيين ومن
بينها المدرعات كيف تابعتم على مدار عام
واكثر من هذه من المعارك البريه على الارض
اداء هذه المدرعات على الارض واداء هذه
المنتجات ميدانيا على الارض وهل انعكس هذا
على خططكم في عمليات الانتاج
الوقت مبكرا لاستغلال جميع الدروس من
النزاع ولكن بالفعل فان فرنسا والجيش
الفرنسي زود القوات الاوكرانيه بمنظومات
مختلفه مثل المدفعيه الدقيقه بعيده المدى
المتمثله بمدفع سيزار الذي ساهمت اركوس
بتزويده بقدرات التنقل وكذلك انواع مختلفه
من المركبات المدرعه لاغراض نقل الجنود او
للاغراض اللوجستيه بلا شك هذا النزاع فيه
الكثير من الدروس التي يمكن ان نستفيد
منها مثل حمايه الافراد بشكل افضل
والتموقع الافضل لاطلاق المدفعيه بعيده
المدى وكذلك التنقل والعمليات اللجوسيه
التي هي عملونا الاساسي وكيفيه ضمان
الاعمال اللوجستيه المناسبه لايصال
المعدات والذخيره للقوات هناك الكثير الذي
يمكن ان نتعلمه وما زلنا نتعلم والقصه
للاسف لم تنتهي بعد
يعني قطاع تصنيع العربات المصفحه يشهد
كبيره وهناك الكثير من الشركات التي لديها
منتجات حول العالم في هذا القطاع تحديدا
لكن ما هو الشيء الذي تعتقدون انه يميز
منتجات اركوس في هذا القطاع تحديدا لهذا
يوجد
بالفعل هناك الكثير من المنافسه ونحن
نحترمها ولكننا متميزون بثلاثه امور اولا
منتجاتنا كلها اثبتت جدارتها فنحن نجهز
القوات المسلحه الفرنسيه منذ عده عقود
ومنتجاتنا تستخدم في انواع مختلفه من
العمليات فنحن متميزون في توفير الحلول
القويه والمعتمده والامر الثاني نحن
متميزون بخدماتنا لان الامر لا يتعلق فقط
بتوفير المنتجات بل كذلك استدامتها طوال
مده استخدامها ونحن قريبون جدا من عملائنا
ونوفر لهم تلك الخدمات وثالثا نحن منفتحون
لتوطين منتجاتنا مع شركائنا من اجل
صناعتها محليا فبهذه المميزات الثلاث
نتميز على منافسين الاساسيين
الان هناك زياده في الانفاق العسكري على
مستوى العالم وتحديدا في اوروبا حتى بعض
الدول الاوروبيه الان لا
ول يعني ميزانيه دفاعيه باحجام كبيره داخل
عدد من هذه الدول في اوروبا لكن كيف
تتعاملون مع هذا الامر هل لديكم الامكانيه
الانتاجيه لكل هذه الطلبات لانه نعلم بان
هذا اثر على انه بات الان لديكم الكثير من
الطلبات والتعاقدات كيف تتعاملون مع هذا
الامر
هذا سؤال مهم وانت محق فقد شهدنا خلال
الاشهر الماضيه زياده في الطلب على
منتجاتنا ولا تزال لدينا القدره على زياده
الانتاج وبالمناسبه هذه الجهود هي من ضمن
متطلبات الصناعه الفرنسيه وهي القدره على
زياده الانتاج من اجل تلبيه الطلب
المتزايد وفيما يخص شركه اركوس لا يزال
لدينا ما يكفي من القدرات السلبيه الطلبات
المتزايده
على مدى سنوات كانت متواجده في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط ولديها بالفعل شراكه مع عدد
من جيوش هذه المنطقه كيف تقيمون هذه
وكذلك الى اي مدى هناك تعاون ما بين اركوس
والشركات العامله في الصناعات الدفاعيه
الان في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
في المنطقه فنحن نتشارك مع الصناعه
المحليه على سبيل المثال لتقديم الخدمات
وتحديث منتجاتنا في تلك الدوله وهذه
الطريقه جيده لاستغلال القيمه الكامله
للمنتجات اما عندما نتعامل مع منتجات
جديده فنحاول كما ذكرت ان نؤسس شراكات
محليه لشراء المنتجات محليا او لتجميعها
لكي تسهم صناعه محليه بنسبه عاليه وهذا ما
لدينا في دول مختلفه من المنطقه ونرغب
بزياده هذا التعاون فمثلا نستطيع احيانا
ان نقوم بتزويد القاعده المتدحرجه وبامكان
الدوله ان تصمم وتصنع بنفسها هيكل المركبه
او المعدات او تكامل الانظمه ونحن مارنون
جدا في هذا السياق